[Music]
so
I'll be talking about various works I
did with my students you can see them
here
and the first one I'll talk to about is
I think that's the only picture I found
of him so
the ones at the bottom are not my
students
Museum
okay
[Laughter]
Okay so
what I'm going to talk about is what
effect do crypto assumptions have on
algorithms
relatively simple settings
so basically what we're going to do is
choose a setting where Randomness helps
we can't do much if it does not help to
begin with
show a good algorithm against an
inactive static adversary then show what
an Adaptive adversary can do and discuss
whether
crypto can help and if it can help show
that the tools that we're using are
essential
and this is of course the the
relationship to to this Workshop we will
try to figure out the minimum assumption
and then of course we'll repeat the
whole thing with a different formula let
me say right at the beginning so
that because I probably prepared way too
much material I'm not going to get to
the end of it like we just
State the general approach I'm asking is
can we automate the process is there
like a a way of figuring out without
doing all the hard work that we're going
to do in this uh talk is there any way
of doing it in are there any simple
criteria we can use and to determine
whether crypto helps and what exactly
are the tools
Okay so
uh there have been lots of examples in
the past I mean I picked a few here uh
maybe the most related one or the
certainly robust property preserving
hash functions
but definitely the the I can think of
many other things here and
and elsewhere
okay what will we see of course
I sort of I thought of talking about two
or two directions one is related to
communication complexity this is work
with the shuttle Cohen uh mostly
appearing in crypto 2022.
and the
relationship the question there is what
is the connection between low
communication complexity protocols
Collision resist hash functions and
secret key agreement protocols and then
we'll talk about streaming and uh
specific record guessing
and the visit would be joint work with
words and relationship to what's called
Mirror games
again and uh I'll end up mentioning a
low memory permutation generation
okay
so let's talk about communication
complexity which I assume we all know
and love
so we have two players Alice and Bob
this is they're not strangers to this
audience and it's involved
okay Alice has an input X Bob has an
input y they talk exchange messages they
wish to compute a function
of their inputs and the exchange
messages and then they want to compute
the value of the the function so somehow
from their communication they should
figure out what what is the value of the
function and the goal is to change as
few bits as possible
the character is given a function how
many bits do we need in order to compute
it
and
um so obviously the complexity of a
protocol is a number of bits of the
worst case and the complexity of a
function is the complexity of the best
step protocol
and we'll concentrate on the quality I
will just mention that it could be other
predicates so the function we'll be
discussing is equality at least X bubble
is why they want to decide whether x
equals
most of the stuff we'll be saying is
relevant to any non-trivial predicate
which does not have redundant rows or
columns
and furthermore we just
maybe it should be separable to have a
predicate that is given x y and x now
you can find a y which separates
but really think of just the quality
let's say
and there's still some issues I mean I
haven't finished telling you exactly
what I mean by a protocol there is the
issue of
how exactly are the messages are we
allowing do we care about the number of
rounds or are we trying to limit very
much the the number of rounds and we'll
be concentrating
on the in this talk it will be
concentrating on the simultaneous
message model where both of them send
the message simultaneously to a referee
who then computes it so they never
directly interact with each other
but some of the stuff what we're saying
is relevant to the interactive model as
well
um
so the deterministic complexities often
in and not always are obviously
for instance for equality for instance
a protocol you need we need to send in
bits
sure issue is the use of Randomness
there is the shared model where the two
parties share a
yeah the random string which is chosen
independently of their inputs so that's
the big that's the big distinction
that's what we're going to concentrate
in this uh talk is exactly what is the
relationship between Randomness and the
inputs so usually in the shared public
Randomness model there is a a shared
random string which is chosen
independently of the interest
and then there is the private brand on
this model where the parties do not they
all they have is their own shared
randomness
pardon
finishes by definition because it's
uniform but but perhaps if it's in the
sky just in crypto we know that you can
there is always a question whether the
inputs are chosen based on the CRS oh
okay so our Venus setting where the
parties are honest or well uh I'll say
exactly who the parties are because I'm
going to introduce and this is perhaps a
character that usually doesn't appear in
communication complexity okay the
anniversary sees the randomness and
chooses the inputs accordingly this is
what we'll be trying to protect
yourselves against such Behavior one
quick question
it's also a slow one it's okay
so uh do we have any uh properties about
the biases on the each bit because we're
assuming this is we're not going to talk
about such things we we will assume we
have the randomness one by five it's
okay truly truly random that's not the
issue the issue is whether somehow uh as
a part of the excitement of running the
protocols somehow the randomness
affected the inputs which can happen we
know that it can happen in a burden also
uh let's say it affected the time it
took a previous protocol somehow the
shape Randomness therefore it affects
the inputs therefore you cannot argue
so
uh so obviously the shared public
Randomness is stronger if you if it's
truly run if it's truly independent it's
stronger than the private management
and these issues are more or less these
two issues are more or less sales
organelle to each other
now what we know about equality in the
interactive model
we know that with shared Randomness to
get constant probability of error you
need just to exchange just one bit yeah
I mean yeah we can talk about
whether we're talking about two-sided
there or one-sided they were in Las
Vegas time everything obviously there
are analogs of every complexity class
you can imagine their analogs uh here uh
we'll be thinking of uh perhaps
two-sided error but with equality you
you really don't have to worry about the
two-sided it's just one one side and if
you're a shared Randomness then uh
you all you need to do is exchange one
bit because for instance you can take
the inner product with think of the
shame Randomness as being defining a
vector over G of two and you take the
inner product X and Y take
Allison to Bob the inner product of the
the shared Randomness with X Bob sees
whether it's consistency then in his
input and announces the result and it
even works I haven't quite said what is
the simultaneous message model it also
works in the simultaneous message
um
okay on the other hand in the
interactive model if you don't have
private Randomness then you you need
login
communication and this is always true
that's the largest difference you can
have from a result of the Illinois man
you you can simulate in the interactive
model not in the simultaneous message
model you can always simulate the the
shared randomness
okay
um
so uh
and another observation is that there
are no
no function in the interactive model and
you you cannot go beneath the login for
any
non-trivial functions
um
okay so what is the simultaneous message
model what
the login is not the randomness of the
rounds
sorry I thought it's a Randomness got it
okay the simultaneous message model you
have a Alison Bob it's each looking at
their own inputs and sending a one to
the referee sending a message to the
referee okay from some message space M A
and B the referee gets the two messages
and decides what the result is
okay so you can think of it as some sort
of sketching each one sends a sketch and
then you can tell the result
the referee can tell the result that's
the I think the big motivation behind
this model though it's already in the
original Yahoo paper on communication he
already defined this model and we want
the probability of error
that the correct result will be computed
with probability of Errors at most
Epsilon to answer you
um
okay so here is for equality testing uh
okay so we'll share Randomness we
already saw more or less saw the the
right protocol what you can do if you
happen if you do have shared Randomness
you just need to we need to send this
thing a little bit but let's see you can
do something
a non-trivial even if you don't have any
children in the private bits model you
can do something what can you do
yeah Alice each one of them encodes
their input using a good error
correcting code
um
they put it inside a square square root
by C square root by c a square a square
yeah The Matrix
and Alice sends a random bro Bob sends a
random uh column at least sends a random
row they intersect in one location the
referee completely ignores the other
stuff and concentrates on the
intersection and see sees whether it's
equal or not and in random code if it's
a run if you think sorry if it's a good
code then a random location is going to
be different with roughly probability
proportional to the alphabet size
so
um
so this gives us something this gives us
a a communication protocol of square
root of him
this is the square root of n
communication protocol
and
[Music]
um
in general uh this is the the lower this
is the best possible Neumann and Sega
they showed
that the size of the two messages there
is at least with some of the sizes at
least square root of in Baba and Kimmel
and in general we'll be using will be
using their approach the product of the
two messages is in
so you'll get of course if at least one
of them is square root of N and in
general you you can get here or instead
of n you can get here the deterministic
complexity you can make the protocol
deterministic with this much
um this is only for equality yes this is
for equality yeah but I'm saying uh you
you the the barbecue mil result is
sufficiently general that you can you
give it deterministic protocol out of it
okay
yourself
[Music]
okay
so a
so the question is can we reduce the
communication complexity by assuming
certain hardness assumptions and what
assumption do we need
and exactly how I already hinted what is
uh What uh
we need to define the model uh more
accurately
okay so what are the issues exactly when
is the randomness chosen as we were
discussing who maintains the state the
randomness is chosen at a certain point
do you need to also know maintain State
from step to step or something like that
and the exact power in terms of
computation of an adversary
and we'll see actually two models the
preset Randomness model
and what we if both of them are made up
names I mean
we made it a limit for this work a
preset Randomness and the free talk
stateful module
and we'll see tight round of
communication complexity assumptions and
model well almost tight bound and when
you close one eye
so
um
okay so in the preset preset Randomness
model we will preset Randomness model is
more or less a when you
there is shared Randomness in the sky in
the series model but somehow the inputs
are chosen based uh perhaps on the on
the uh on this shared randomness
somehow clicked because
affected who knows why
so in this model we'll see that breaking
the square different lower Bound for
equality implies the existence of a
distributional collision resistant hash
functions we'll see it in a constructive
Manner and uh assuming uh the the
as I said I'm going to talk mostly about
the simultaneous message model I mean it
definitely simplifies their life because
you know exactly there is one message
from each party and that's it but we
also have the same type of results
regarding interactive communication but
there we instead of square root of n of
course we have longing if you go below
login for a
communication complexity for interactive
communication then you you have you are
using distributional Collision resistant
hash functions there are no Protocols of
constant communication
whatever assumption you need and as I
mentioned we'll be using the proof their
low amount proof for a well actually we
even we'll be using it even for the the
interactive case even though it's real
proof is closer please and those of you
uh who are smart which I assume is
everyone here you probably figured out
that if you have Collision resistant
hash functions then you can use it in
order to improve the communication
those who are smart or those who can
read
I'm not so smart how do you break the
login
oh okay I I meant the uh for the
simultaneous message model but even even
for the but you can break the login even
for the interactive one
okay they will have something to think
about
not that smart you know okay
um okay so this is for the preset
randomness
for the uh what we call the stateful
free talk model
what we assume is that Alice and Bob
talk to each other now it's now we are
let's say outside the model of sketching
before it was exactly like sketching now
we're think of it Alice and Bob talked
to each other maintain a state before
the inputs are chosen
Big Talk they maintain a secret state
each one has their own state
and the communication complexity is
measured only after the pre-processing
phase but a
also the inputs are chosen after the
pre-person phrase so the adversary sits
in the middle listens to their
conversation and then selects the inputs
and a
what we'll see is that very efficient
protocols
against a rushing anniversary of course
they'll have to Define everything here
imply the existence of secret key
agreement
okay
and by very efficient uh me I mean that
for a c bit protocol you have
probability of error which is let's say
2 to the minus point seven eight point
seven C
something like that so you know for each
bit you're getting something essentially
almost something
so if you have such a protocol then we
know how to convert it into a secret key
exchange secret key ingredient protocol
yeah
no no no they don't see the secret State
otherwise we're there is no no Advantage
he may as well choose it may be part of
the public landing yes
the secret stake is secretly for a
reason it's called secret State because
it's it's it's it's not part of the
power of that
you you want to say that you know you
cannot uh make the protocols more
efficient without essentially relying on
assumptions uh and then kind of I guess
if you do rely on assumptions you can do
it easily and yeah in both cases in both
cases
if in this case if you assume that you
have a synchronic agreement protocol
then you have a c-bit protocol with
probability two to the minus
seeing it
yeah so you'll end it's good against a
rushing adversary okay
[Music]
okay so the randomness
it's a good question
um
but uh
the the issue here is that you I mean
everything you can do with correlated
Randomness if you have secret key
agreement you can do if you have so at
least if you have a Bluetooth transfer
you can do a review the other way
because the other one is not
um
in correlated Randomness the adversary
sees in a Randomness right yeah so
in the other direction it's because of
the amplification
3.7 it's really Limited
let's let's take it off tomorrow just
just not too confused with the years
so just a reminder about assumptions in
crypto so we have a bunch of things that
are equivalent one we function in a
group
uh a whole bunch of applications that
are equivalent to private key encryption
and whatever
that's minicrypt we have a collision
resistant hash function
and we have secret key agreement it's
not well I mean secret key agreement
definitely implies one-way functions crh
we think that it's close to it but not
quite it's not
and we have Oracle separation of all
these assumptions
and
um
it's worth mentioning uh so Collision
resistant hash functions means that it's
hard to find in collusion and a
in order to separate one-way hash
functions from series you could consider
Collision finder given a collision
finder one-way functions do exist but
crhs of course doing all images
and the random Oracle is an example of
of separating a secret key agreement
from crh because
what
so
as we mentioned Collision resistant hash
functions we want the family A little
hash function we want them to be
efficiently computable
given h a description of a little H and
given X it's easy to compute h of X it's
hard to find religion for every
polynomial adversary in large enough
security parameter
or a random
a little age in the family
given a h it's hard to come up with X
different from X Prime that collide
should be negligible in a security
parameter level
and as I mentioned you can separate them
as it's originally from Simon
than Simon and 98 and using a random
Collision finally
and the other observation is that if
once you can compress by a little you
can compress by a whole lot so if you
can chop one bit you can chop many many
bits
okay distributional uh Collision
a resistant hash function
it's a family of hash functions where
you it's hard to come up with the random
Collision they were defined by The Grove
and shy
and
um the Black Box separation still holds
from Black Box separation from one-way
function still holds and
[Music]
um
the
um the interesting thing is that
with such a dcrh you can still do some
interesting things that we don't know
how to do with it
concentrons statistically hiding
commitments
okay
so these are we're starting with the
with the preset randomness
so
yeah
with caveats I mean right that's why a
okay the question regarding this work is
whether you can get rid whether you can
do directly series
we we don't know how to use their stuff
to to do directly crh without the
caveats that they have
okay
sorry sorry
[Music]
I think not
no no
we don't know are impossible
so it means Oracle separation
this place
okay
um
so how do we get how do we get the same
protocols from CLA well in the preset
Randomness model let's say it is a
simultaneous message model
if you have a function going from n Bits
to Lambda bits uh then you have a
protocol with complexity square root of
Lambda instead of square root of n
a
in the uh preset public coins
interactive model you can get log Lambda
and uh what do you do well the public
string is that defines the hash function
page and you replace x with h of X and
continue as before
that's it so instead of having an end
bit input you have a Lambda bit
so we're breaking the square root of n
lower bound
in this model
okay
um
so uh
now we want to go to to lower bound so
we want to somehow start with the
protocol and Define a hash function
okay so we have when you use a series
you also need to change like nature to
be efficient better yeah as I said
here's the protocol is nature is nature
chooses the we're now assuming so our
actors are Alice and Bob of course by
Russell Lee
uh let's think of the referees being
determinist we have Alice and Bob we
have to be also now because we're adding
the computational assumptions they have
they themselves have to be efficient
we have the randomness is chosen the CRS
or whatever that is chosen and then
based on that
here this is how it works based at the
the randomness is chosen the adversary
sees the randomness and chooses X and Y
and if we are assuming
that the adversary is efficient
information
so after seeing the random string RP
the public string X and Y are chosen
this is nature
this is the only thing the adversary
does yes in this protocol there are now
I mean
actually we'll see in the rushing model
where they they can see you know choose
inputs gradually and things like that
see what the Alice is sending and then
decide what Bob Bob's input is what here
let's keep it simple here
nature sees the common random string
chooses the input sex
Y and then they send the the inputs
very sorry the message under inputs of
course they send it to the referee who
has to determine whether x equals
okay
um
and uh
and now let's just uh just to uh
so RP is going to be the common
Randomness then to put spacer a capital
x and capital Y for Alex and Bob
Alice gets Little X Bob gets little y m
a and MB are message spaces whatever
Alice and Bob can send to each other in
innocent to to a
or the referee and they're sending
little a
um little M A from capital M A and
little MB from capital a m b
and they also have private randomness of
course that is not known to the
adversary to begin with otherwise it
will be in the humanistic setting
um or not exactly the two minutes sorry
we wouldn't be in the deterministic city
no actually but we do also have their
own shared private randomness
and uh and so Allison's uh
as I said Ali says and a bobson and b
and the referee decides uh on the result
and Alice's distribution is given x
given R A her private random tape
that determines her message and same
thing regarding
okay so this is a what a protocol looks
like
[Music]
um
okay
so what we'll be using yeah
you measure error so what's the arrow
what's the notion of her right
what's the notion of error in this
context whether the referee outputs is
the correct result whether if it says
one there are equal if it's a zero
they're not for a letter of messages or
for every person
no not for everything
so the notion of error is
the adversary force and wrong result
number on Bob
the adversary he knows the protocol
privacy who knows the protocol knows the
shared randomness
if you can find an XML y
and make Allison but maybe there are
three output the wrong result then
[Music]
um
then then there were three then the
adversary succeeds
okay we want the probability that the
adversary succeeds to be bounded by
Epsilon
it's not it doesn't make sense at this
point to talk about for any X in any one
right so if the adversary was unbounded
the previous normal definition exactly
any does there exists such an input
exactly
but then we know that you cannot go
that's a good point
without computational assumption we're
back to the to the model where we're
let's say bubbling Kim approve the lower
levels
of course it does but here so again
you see the you see the the adversary
sees the common Randomness chooses X and
Y
yes uh I mean what if like I
well it's because like question or
trivial if I design like a protocol for
every adversary like
oh oh no no no here okay the adversary
you said like it's okay
you decide you design the protocol RP is
chosen the adversary chooses yeah so
it's here like we have like a security
that's like every adversary yeah like
yes exactly so what happens if like say
there's like a particular distribution
over XY that's of interest and
it's not clear that it's equivalent but
we know that it's very hard to take
advantage of it how can you say that you
don't have a universal Collision fund
you don't know how to take advantage of
the fact
you know but we know with as usual we we
don't know exactly how we don't know
exactly anything about how the inputs
are chosen so it's not very reasonable
to design a protocol assuming you know
um because you don't know it you don't
have enough information about exactly
how X and Y were chosen how to model it
that's just computational problems I say
how do you I mean you are in the setting
you are not sure exactly how it's how
your protocol is going to be used so yes
okay I mean that sounds I think what
Johnny is trying to say is like if you
think of the PHD analogy
uh if you could use kind of an in some
bigger sense it's like prg instead of a
series
instead and maybe that you can actually
do you use because you you know because
you'll be fooling it will be fooling the
the particular episode no but I don't
think it makes sense
Escape
because you don't know exactly the
process of how how the inputs were
chosen your organizations
of course it's true but here with the
protocol like I think kind of sketching
or something like that I don't see how
we could make sense to assume that you
know how language are chosen
okay so as I mentioned okay so the
we'll be using characterizing multi-sit
for every X forever input X there exists
a multi-step of possible messages
characterizing Its Behavior
instead of running uh Alice to begin
with we can approximate the protocol by
a uniform sample from this mountain so
so this is not very surprising because
they could by definitely because by
definition I think there exists a huge I
mean all possible messages are such a
that's it but the point is that you have
not a very you don't need a very large
uh you don't need a very large
multi-stick
and that's the point and such a
multi-set can be fine found by sampling
by running the protocol relatively few
times you could find such a notice
and
the property that we want from this
multi-set from this sub distribution so
to speak is that for every
possible message that Bob will send
so we don't know what we don't care
about Bob's input we care about Bob's
message so every possible message that
Bob will send
the behavior on a on a true Alice in the
behavior and choosing Alice from TX
should be roughly uh the same the
probability of the the referee outputs
one should be roughly the same in both
cases
so for every so that's the important
thing is that we're doing it for every
possible message that Bob sends not for
every possible input that box this
allows us to
um sort of we'll do at the end we'll do
some sort of Union bound this will allow
us to do Union bound overall possible
messages rather than all possible inputs
and therefore we'll get a the result
that we want
and a
a so as I mentioned you can simply
for every for every possible message Bob
send what is Q so Q you take Q you
choose a random message in t sub X yes
okay
and so the way we're construct it
is will simply sample a
t times
where T is something like log the
message signs instead of Alice
of Mom sorry
sample from it t times and this is going
to be a good characterizing multi-set
with the constant probability
yes we do
come on really nice simulations
uh all possible yeah okay
we're not trying what we want to say
that I don't care once it once I fix the
eggs
I don't care what message Bob is what
message Bob says I want the property
that we'll have is that the referees
behavior is going to be the same on both
this distribution and on a true protocol
I think if I can uh
she's saying think about all the what
the referee does with any one of the
possible messages from Bob is a
distinguisher this is kind of a
generator with a small space that is
fooling all of this thing with a small
not small
exactly I think that you you get
yes
okay
okay so uh so this is essentially uh how
what we're going to do the way we'll
construct the hash function
um is uh it's going to be defined by the
public uh random string which is going
to be fixed and by P random tapes
for Alex
and uh for any X the value of the
function is this is the multi set to be
simply the motives of the behavior of
Alice with all those uh take random
types and all those little T random
poops
and as you can see what what is the size
of the output it's going to be T times
the size of these messages the size of
these messages is the size of
um
it's m a the size of the messages with
Alice sins so the total size is going to
be the size of the messages of Bob so
the size of the messages of Alice times
the size of the messages of mob which uh
if you break a n then it's going to be
less than n so you simply get some
compression
once uh once you have a non-trivial
protocol View
and so we have the function HS
compressing
and uh
if you have an x and x Prime would share
a characterizing multi-set and then use
a bad input for the protocol because you
can pick them you can pick x and x Prime
and then choose y that separates them
one of them in the case of equality and
then the sum of the fail on one or
either on X Y or on X Prime y the the
sum of the federal probabilities is
let's say at least 0.8 so at least one
of them
[Music]
did so
um
so uh we can use it so the whole point
is you can we can take this and use it
as a collision fine we can use in a
collision breaking the H is the bcrh to
a one breaking pi as a computational one
as a computational in quality protocol
and uh we will use the Collision finder
in order to find bad inputs
so we go from
a
in
Breaking the protocol we go from
breaking the hash function to Breaking
the protocol and therefore we have a
construction if we have a good protocol
we conclude that we have a good
construction for this area which is
in the
why at this point of course the question
is I mean everything I said sounds like
uh like a series not a dcrich
but no the point is not all of them are
going to be characterizing it we can't
quite we can't quite cover everything
so we're not going to be characterizing
for everyone and you're characterizing
almost
so therefore we need the dcrh
and the interesting questions can we
might ask this
okay so this is a this is regarding the
preset model I see that have been really
been too ambitious I'm probably not
going to go beyond the next topic they
they went on a preset on a free talk
so let's what do we mean by stick from
three talk so Alice and Bob exchanged
messages freely we don't count it when
this all this happens before the inputs
are chosen it happens after the children
of course they will decide on there
they maintain subsequent State the
adversary eavesdrops and then selects
the inputs
the communication is measured only after
the free pre-processing
okay now I mentioned rushing adversary
what do we mean uh so the inputs are
chosen by computational boundary
diversary depending on the public
discussion but in the rushing adversary
the the
the referee's first is what message
Alice is sending and only then decide
what is the input to borrow
there's more power to
move and uh so we give more powerful
adversary
to give more power to the adversary
um
so this is one thing we allow then we
also have a patient adversary where the
adversary sees starts a session and
decides whether this is going to be the
one where uh it's corrupts or no
do it several times until it decides now
sees Alice's message then says this is
the one I'm going to keep
so these are messages multiple sessions
with different inputs each time the
adversary chooses the inputs adaptively
all the time again I don't know so this
is a weakness of you could say weakness
of our lower bound because we need we're
going to use both of these things I
don't think you really need them to
listen
or a way the way we'll convert an
adversary to one breaking the secret to
sorry the way we'll convert a protocol
link one that is a secret achievement it
will use we'll be needing these two
properties
okay secret key agreement which we owe
again
well we have two parties please exchange
messages they have no prior common
information at the end they agree with a
secret uh the key should be secret so no
um eavesdropping adversary assumingly
passive adversary can compute the key
with non-evitable Advantage actually we
want you to be
you know distinguishing from random
point out that you can go from one to
the other but
then they of course public encryption
implies a secret key ingredient
once we have secret care agreement
things are really nice
uh you can you you you have a good
protocol with the stateful preset public
Randomness with with uh with very little
communication and it will be good
against these types of rushing impatient
and whatever it is
so here is the other product looks like
you execute the secret key agreement
the secret state is the key of course
each one of them
uh the adversary listens in besides on X
and Y and given the input use the key as
a pairwise independent hash function
from G
and send G of x
okay so
Allison's G of X Bob sends G of Y and
the referee simply with the science
given G of X and G of Y whether they're
equal or not that tells it whether X and
Y are Z
had it been a truly random key there is
nothing Alice involved if nothing the
resolution to do and
um
and therefore if that the address can do
anything in this case
um we can distinguish
and we can distinguish the key from
being true
and if you think about it I mean given G
of X it tells you nothing about you g of
Y so therefore you cannot choose why
after C but the very fact that you can
choose y after seeing jewelry will help
you
and also you have no idea whether you're
going to succeed or not so you know the
fact that you can be patient doesn't
help you this way
okay so we know that for equality You by
in this model by sending C bits you can
get probability of two to the minus C
plus
now a claim that I can go from such a
protocol into to a secret key ingredient
but we'll be choosing a we'll need a lot
of amplification
we'll do a secret bit agreement it's
going to be a single bit and it's not
going to be a perfect one but luckily
for us we have amplification and
procedure for that so an alphabet a
secret kilogramming protocol
is one where Alex and Bobby saves
messages in the end they decide on a
single bit
Alice outputs B and Bob outputs B Prime
with probability at least one plus Alpha
over two equal
they have agreement
in secrecy where no no PPT which gets us
an input the transcript and guesses the
agreed bit given that b equals B Prime
uh can succeed with probability greater
than one minus beta over two
okay so if there if they agreed on the
bed the probability that the adversary
guesses them it looks like this
now this is a secret B bit agreement
and it's Alpha and better negligible we
get secret
we get a secret key agreement we can get
whatsoever for one bit we can have it
for many years
and what challenge did he showed that
you can go from a alphabet a secret key
agreement when Once one minus Alpha over
one plus Alpha is less than beta you can
go to all the way to negligible
okay and the time is polynomial
so we'll get a pretty bad secret bit
agreement and we'll amplify it using
knowledge
and
um
foreign
C and it's immune to Russian and patient
adversaries this implies the existence
of secret key agreement protocol
okay so this is where the with the show
and the way the protocol works is the
way they we turn a protocol for equality
into a protocol for
[Music]
um
we'll start with the quality and turn it
into protocol for secret agreement
the protocol we have how
a and Tau B the secret sense of Alex and
Bob following their free talk phase and
an input as we said an input X and Y by
Alice is going to send m a which is a
function of your secret state in a and
Bob is going to send a MB which is a
function of a secret State and my
and uh so here is uh we have the
protocol looks like Alice and Bob
communicate
uh they generate a secret state
Alice selects a random business triangle
zero one and since the pair of two
inputs x0 and X1
and then she evaluates M A which is what
she would have said in the communication
protocol with x b either x 0 or X1 and
her secret state
and uh and this is her message in the
protocol for uh this is the word m a she
sends Bob the pair M A in X1 always x y
Bob looks at the product Bob evaluates
MB and a X1 with his secret state so Bob
doesn't send any message it just
evaluates in a bit and Bob's output bit
is whatever the referee would have said
given M A and MB
so click for instance if things work
nicely and X1 was chosen
b equals one in another no errors or
anything then they agree on the common
the bit they agrees is one Alexis
chooses b equals one what doesn't make
any mistake and sort of the free doesn't
referee plus Bob do not make mistakes
then B Prime would also be equal to one
and hopefully
otherwise we hope that the if she
chooses zero then we hope that Bob will
figure out if the Bob plus the referee
will figure out that X that X1 is not
really the input of a on on which Alice
executed the protocol executed Ma and
the side only zero that's the thing
and using that you we can show
so we have a pretty this is part of the
reason why we get a weak result we can
show that this protocol has these
parameters Al Alpha which is
remember one very small Alpha here we
have a pretty large Alpha yeah one minus
two to the minus C over two and better
which is 2 to the minus C over two
and agreement is follows roughly the
lines I mentioned before
the agreement is going to be simple
secrecy we need to construct an
adversary
where equality from an adversary
breaking the the SBA you could break the
secret bit agreement
we want to create from it an adversaries
are breaking the equality
and this is a essentially what you do
View
and
um
the analysis shows that it works but we
are using really using the fact that we
we need to get almost perfect
probability
that ratio the probability should really
be exponential in the number of bits
and uh so this
um
this raises a lot of questions uh the
one I mentioned of course is whether
crhs are equivalent and the I mean we do
we still have a gap between dcrh and
foreign
[Music]
and probably you can get up too long
but the way what we claim what we
guarantee is long run it's open with
yeah yeah you want to you want to go
beyond you want to go beyond the
right uh
we want protocols with worse error
probability
and uh and then you know just give me
you know log login protocol which has
probability
you really need the Russian Embassy
and
um
and then uh
and then uh we didn't mention it all
rushing in the preset model you can
think of
a brushing adversary in this case as
well
so
um let me finish here I'll just show you
uh the pictures of my students I did not
get to talk about just a little bit you
didn't hear about the work but at least
you'll see their pictures thank you
[Applause]
okay
just like uh so I think the secret is
and
like in the protocol would basically
hear about library renza and x0 and XY
um
like I'm wondering does this show like
this is like actually it's like a
sufficient distribution
for like
for you for any particle it was to
design like a protocol to look at or
like in the security you actually need
to oh that you're saying that give less
power to to the adversary yeah
but I'm wondering the thing is I'm not
sure how it works with the patient
your thing
what happens if you work with a patient
because a patient a patient adversary
can influence X and Y A x 0 and X1 right
a patient we said that a patient
adversary sees chooses and sorry X and Y
X zero and X1 from the other secrets
that adversary sees uh the message
chooses X sees the message on X then
chooses y
so therefore even though here I
mentioned the way I describe the
protocol the way I describe the the
secret key agreement protocol I
described it with a random x0 and X1 you
do have you do have the power to reject
x0 and X1 but by the patience so to
speak to a patient you can you can
modify
foreign
[Music]
thank you